so now here's the other part as well
everybody right now is uh uh it's all
about the positioning game
so you're watching everybody it's all
about it people don't even know what's
going on right now the other part is
positioning so what is positioning
positioning is there's going to be
different types of people that are
positioning there are those right now
that are positioning to say
well i'm younger i'm going to be running
uh in 2024. dude i need trump on my side
to come show up to my rap the josh
hawley's of the world the ted cruz's of
the world
of course great there are those that are
sitting there saying dude i'm gonna have
to do business with these guys i'm never
running for office
i'm just gonna stay congressman or
senate i gotta align myself with who
pelosi schumer's and mitch you know
these guys are the world so those are
the guys that you know some of them some
of those guys that are lining with them
maybe your pants maybe some of those
guys right
maybe pence wants to run but he wants to
say i'm more for the constitution
than not for trump and then there are
those that are aligning themselves right
now to say
dude all i need i just need a job with
cnn or fox that's all i know i'm sorry
some guys are saying
they're a lobbyist position i need a
those guys make some good money
but everybody's right now posturing with
their position
so some of the people are saying things
that they don't really believe in
they're just saying it because
it benefits the position they're solving
for i don't know if that makes sense or
not so totally it's talking basically of
their next five moves that's
exactly what they're thinking you know
but but somebody has to talk about the
truth and
get people to realize what's going on
you know for us we're just kind of
sharing our thoughts go ahead
you know extremism is a is a very bad
thing and no matter what side you're on
and if you're
a far-right republican and you're an
extremist you're looking for someone to
blame right now because that's human
nature that's what they're going to do
they want to they want to find an outlet
you know to say oh see it's their fault
and they're going towards
mike pence right now that's who their
scapegoat is that's who that's who they
want to blame that he didn't have the
courage to stand up and do that
i don't blame mike pence you know i
don't think he had the power to do it
number one
and i don't think he's that type of
person and i don't think you can put
that type of responsibility on one
person
when x amount of votes were cast for joe
biden and now you're asking one guy
to stand up just because he was told to
so i don't like the way the extreme
right
is blaming pence here's the other
question i have was yesterday the
beginning
or the end was yesterday at the point
where we see we've hit rock bottom we
can only go up from here maybe we can
find some common ground
work a little bit together if
republicans and the conservatives have a
problem with who's running this country
and most of them do
you got a chance to do something about
it in two years or is that the beginning
where people are just going to grind in
depends dig in and and and make things
even worse i'm hoping and i'm praying
it's a great question that we can move
up well i think that's a great question
and i think it depends on where trump
goes from here i mean the
clearly these people i know i'm talking
about the extremists
are hanging on his every word i mean a
lady lost her life yesterday because she
is that [ __ ] but she wasn't an innocent
victim she was a q a
supporter not that that means you should
die but like she had some far out there
man you're going into the capitol
building you're taking 100 percent risk
100 but um let's talk about mike pence
for a second
let's talk about myself stay on this
question if it's if it's on this
question if it's around this question
stay on this question if it's not move
on well the question is where where can
we go from here
again again again it revolves around
trump if trump i don't think so
you don't think that i don't think so
let me explain
be cocky in your predictions okay
confident in your preparation
humble in your victory and laws if those
who
won the victorious group comes out cocky
you're gonna drag this [ __ ] out
this is not on trump trump officially
has no control
if you're saying if biden starts acting
cocky not just biden the laugh
the media biden every if they act cocky
you're putting salt on the wound and
you're going to piss people off
define cocky because i want to
understand let me explain you're like
you know
you knock a guy out beat your ass dog
you don't get in the guy's face you
knocked him out step back
exactly and then you go and say hey man
are you good is everything good i'm you
know hey man
fighters and they're hugging you dude
you walk out listen i understand lost
sucks i've lost myself dude i hope
just i respect your fight you know i
respect and you move on right
okay win with classes yes now so so now
obviously trump is not losing with you
know to say oh he's losing with class no
he's pissed off he thinks voter fraud
happened
fine but the win he's not the winner
he's not the winner jordan when he won
he still had class
we won okay class hey i want to give
respect to the opponent
but he won okay the winners are in
charge right now
not the loser the loser officially has
no control what can he do
nothing he's done he does another rally
like this
let me put it to you this way if he
entices people
to go out there and do another rally
like this do not be surprised if he's
100
banned from all of social media like
alex jones and do you think that's
uh valid if he does it to the point
where you're getting people to be hurt
yes it is a very good argument to be
made if you go to that level i don't run
those companies i'm freedom of speech so
to me it's about freedom of speech and
i'm not about
but you cannot use your speech to create
war you know stuff you can't do
especially a starting point
there is a tipping point where he should
be banned from social media well first
of all
like i said to you again if i'm going on
social media and saying like if i said
right now
you're upset about it to all the second
amendment folks grab your guns let's go
to dc
they should shut me down yeah okay they
should take that video down that's not a
what am i talking about exactly i mean
that's so real i think he has
uh three tweets he quote unquote has
to delete and if so they'll put his
account back in the next 12 hours if not
they apparently are going to shut his
account down for good i think he i think
i
i look he's not going to listen to
anybody yeah
i think there's one person he will
listen to i think there's one person he
will listen to who's that i think it's
only his wife
i think he you think he's actually going
to listen to her i think he absolutely i
don't think so
i think you know let me tell you why
yeah i think you absolute you may want
to turn off your micai because
everything you're drinking we're hearing
uh um i think he will listen to his wife
if his wife uh uh threatens him says
look i just want to let you know you're
making it harder on my kid
baron and you're bringing a lot of
negative attention on him and if i have
to choose between you and my kid it's my
kid
okay and i think you're crossing the
line so you may want to calm down a
little bit but that's just my process i
i gotta tell you
i 1000 disagree with you on that point
i don't think he's gonna listen to
melania i don't think he's gonna listen
to ivanka i don't think he's gonna
listen to
don jr or eric or whatever the other kid
is or
i don't think he's gonna listen to
anybody i don't think there is a person
he will listen to more than his wife
you're talking about somebody back to
the mike pence thing you're talking
about somebody
has there ever been a more loyal vice
president than mike pence this guy
ate a [ __ ] sandwich a trump [ __ ]
sandwich it was like
man that tasted good guys get on the
train and he threw mike pence under the
bus said
what did he say exactly yesterday he
said basically mike pence is weak and he
won't do what uh
that was that was in the heat of the
moment you're talking about
someone incredibly loyal that you just
throw under the bus in your final days
yeah but that
he throws everybody under the bus okay
that's my point okay but let me
everybody goes under the bridge
counterpoint here we all know that his
ego drives everything the most important
thing
to himself is himself i believe
he is concerned of how this looks i mean
in his statement did you notice one of
the things he said in his statement
he referred to himself as having the
greatest
first term presidency in the history of
america
i mean even in his in his um release
where he's
conceding essentially and saying that
there's going to be a peaceful
transition
he's also putting the spotlight on him
and saying hey this was the most
successful first term
ever so i someone
someone has to be in his ear he has to
listen to someone and say
it is time now to pull back a little bit
you know
you can only hurt yourself more at this
point and and his legacy
will be destroyed forever if he
continues to do this now the problem is
there's a certain fringe element that
hangs on his words and are looking for
marching orders basically from him so he
has to be very very careful
he has to be because he has true
believer followers look demon kennedy's
had true believer followers true
believer followers will go through the
wall for you and
and he has to take that power
responsibly he can't be throwing that
weight around telling people to do
whatever because people will move
on his words so when you're somebody
like that you have to be very very
careful
he has to be very careful are you
suggesting that he's going to all of a
sudden
have grace and willingness to listen i
mean you're talking about somebody
and i don't mean this like you know
what's the best thing he can do you know
what's the best thing he can do
go away for a little while for six
months paula jackman well layla for sure
if he loves his country he needs to do
that and i think he loves his country
listen we can all have wishful thinking
here but yeah this guy is an egomaniac
narcissist and he's he's made it to the
body whoever becomes a president
cool yeah but he ain't laying low for
two days yeah nobody because he's
over six months ain't nobody becoming a
president who isn't narcissistic
ego all that other stuff just so no i
disagree you can have a big ego but you
don't necessarily need to be a
narcissist
oh anybody that becomes a president you
have a little bit of thinking you're
better than everybody else and that's
needed by the way
you kind of a smart guy he needs to get
away from the dialogue of the election
was stolen
that's not getting him anywhere i mean
that's all he's going to ever say the
rest of his life
he'll be on his deathbed saying that
yeah if he does that
um he ain't changing patents
i didn't say he is or he's not so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you